we bought an old laptop on eBay from
some guy and restored all the personal
data not knowing what we're going to
find so first I took out the hard drive
from the laptop and recovered 126 000
files from the disk that were deleted we
found anime by Miyazaki photos like a
mosque which Google has found out is
located in Top Copy turkey and you
wouldn't believe it but
a passport
now we know that it's a her and her name
is Helen although she's a German citizen
she lives in London we see the town
height and age the passport expired in
February last year but if only this
computer had got to the attackers
earlier and that's not all we've also
found out info about her work family
Hobbies places she goes and buys stuff
yep crazy watch our big video to find
out more dangers in your laptop